the learn from the legends lecture now
the past couple lectures have been you
know pretty standard we've been going
over some very famous people of the past
right first one I did here I believe I
went over Geller the last one I went
over Blackburn and I think that's all
I've done maybe there's one more I feel
like one more but I don't remember my
memory is terrible
and today I thought I would switch it up
a little bit instead of doing a player
we're gonna go do a tournament so this
is one of the most important tournaments
that ever happened in the game of chess
we're gonna be looking at the
tournament's st. Petersburg 1914 so this
one was an important tournament for many
reasons partially politically so anybody
remember what happened in 1914 yes do
you remember you were there about
revolution okay so we have you know some
kind of tension in Russia right some
some things are going on also is there
tension between Russia and somebody some
austrian-hungarian empire maybe a little
bit yeah some like okay so I miss you a
couple of people didn't yeah yeah so
this was actually before the war before
all hell broke loose in in Europe mainly
and in Russia
this is April of 1914 so so you know
yeah this is about a hundred and one
years ago and and it was a tournament
that was supposed to commemorate the
10th anniversary of the st. Petersburg
chess society and because of this
society being you know quite strong they
wanted to invite the top 20 players in
the world a couple of them had to
decline for old age for example we never
had to decline out of all days there
were a couple of others that weren't
able to make it while some of them
to decline of our political tensions so
a lot of players from the
austrian-hungarian empire were not able
to attend for example I believe tartakov
was unable to attend Vidmar was unable
to attend so in the strongest players at
the time but still the tournament was
quite strong we have a photo of some of
the participants here reigning world
champion at the time was emanuel Lasker
so still Laskaris world champion in 1914
and this is and his biggest competitor
in the tournament was of course the
Cuban challenger josé raúl capablanca
who's seven years after this tournament
would dethrone Lasker in Havana Cuba
so besides them there are very strong
players Rubinstein Akiba Rubinstein one
of the strongest players of the era
Janoski of course very very famous
player we talked about Blackburn a
couple of last lecture was also a
participant this was his last tournament
and you can see he was already at a
rather advanced age you know with the
white beard and alcohol taking his
effects whisky is his favourite Gunzburg
was a very famous player very strong he
actually smashed Blackburn in out in a
match like smash something like +6 or
something its destruction then from
America our famous Frank Marshall
inventor of the Marshall gambit and the
two Russian qualifiers the first time in
the world that they really heard of
Alexander a Jochen or known in America's
Alekhine it was really his first
appearance in a in a strong
international event as a strong player
and of course the father of modern chess
nimzowitsch now there were a couple of
other players so we're gonna take a look
at the standings the tournament actually
was held in a little bit of an unusual
setup there was the preliminaries and
the top five qualified to the finals if
you
so how are the points carried over it
was a little strange I don't think there
was ever a another tournament made like
that but it was kind of interesting so
we see that you know Blackburn in
Greensburg from England ended up
finishing last along with you know Suki
poor Ginsburg only scored one out of ten
and well it wasn't so much his fault I
mean look at the names in this list
Capablanca Lasker Marshall
Jochen Rubinstein you and bursting is
supposed to be a really really strong
player the only pleasure had a mentioned
sig Bert Irish from Germany also made an
appearance also a very strong player one
of the founders of modern you know
modern chess concept so we can see that
whole several kappa blanka just
destroyed the preliminary eight out of
ten point and a half ahead of both
starch and Lasker Marshall a yogi were
also able to qualify with the six out of
ten aliens only lost game two kappa
blanka so the finals were by the way
this was a really long tournament you
know like for us the u.s. championship
in nowadays is pretty long this
tournament lasted a month now I'd like
25 days like a month it was a month and
it was followed with great intensity you
know there was newspapers coming in
people would literally packed in like
sardines just to be able to walk into
the smoke-filled room of this tiny st.
Petersburg chess society and be able to
watch the games actually the flat that
was there the st. Petersburg chess
society still stands today and it's
possible to visit it the woman that
lives there is pretty receptive to
visitors that want to just look at the
doors that hosted this magnificent event
that's a private flat now however the
finals were not nearly as dominated by
kappa blanka instead world champion
Emanuel Ax Lasker came in with a
crushing performance and now you have to
remember
these are just the final results but
they aggregate with the preliminaries
Lasker Lasker won the tournament half a
point ahead of Jose Raul kappa blanka so
he crushed the final just enough to
overtake kappa blanka and we're gonna
start the lecture off with the key game
this is the 19th round of the tournament
now notice that this is a five person
round-robin which makes it awkward for
pairings because that means that
somebody has to buy on every round so it
makes the tournament longer than it
needs to be but okay this is the 19th
round of the st. Petersburg 1914
tournament and Lasker is trailing
capablanca to keep his chances of
winning the tournament alive he must win
all of the experts said Lasker is going
for the throat you know this is I there
they even had nicknames for this guys
back then I mean Lasker was known as the
poet of chess
whereas kappa blanka was known as the
human-machine because he would be able
to calculate and he was able to play
with such precision in the endgame but
last year instead of going for a very
aggressive you know very weird to also
type of game he played something really
quiet and despite that he ended up
creating a masterpiece so we're gonna
take a look at the game as soon as I
find it yep Lasker against Jose Raul
Kappa Blanc so we gotta understand that
this is before the match all right this
is before the match of 1921 this is
still Lasker as world champion and we
have the games
efore e5 Knight f3 knight c6 there
should be five a-six and Bishop c6 the
exchange variation a move that's
considered to be a little dubious Bishop
a4 is by far the more common move but
Bishop c6 tends to a little bit of a
quieter game it exchanges pieces and it
normally goes to end games which is a
little strange considering that when you
think was the best endgame player to
have ever lived kappa blanka probably
should come to mind
but Oscars like I'm world champion I got
this nobody in the audience really
believed that you know this would work
but you know after people saw this game
they didn't doubt D takes c6 d4 takes
takes with the Queen takes takes
remember Alaska must win and this is
reminiscent of our game that happened
many many many years later there was a
certain Kasparov Karpov match in which
Kasparov had to absolutely win the last
game to become world champion or lose
the title and everybody expected us
white to start either efore and go for a
sharp Sicilian maybe try to outplay his
opponent in some kind of real opus or d4
and try to find a novelty in the
nimzo-indian but instead he chose Knight
f3 g3 Bishop g2 played the slowest ready
possible I'm one brilliantly much like
Lasker in this game Bishop d6 now I'm
not gonna get bogged down by the theory
of this position obviously a lot has
changed in the last 101 years but you
know Bishop d6 is no longer considered
to be mainline 93 97 castles castles in
f4 so everything seems fine so far why
does have a little bit of a space
advantage and his central pawns are
obviously quite nice that being said
black has a pair of bishops on a very
very very solid position it's very hard
to crack rook e8 was played and this is
already considered to be a slightly
dubious move now of course a 5 is not
really an issue because as soon as you
play e5 you give up control over all of
the light squares so as soon as I play
Bishop c5 Bishop e3 even the immediate
trade which is quite unnecessary but
possible Knight a5 Bishop back h5
creates a blockade that nowadays we're
very familiar with thanks to the Berlin
defence of the real opus you got the
Berlin setup with the pawn on e5 and a
blockade on the light squares you know
as long as why it's unable to push the
pawn to g4 it doesn't seem like there's
gonna be much of an
way of making progress Lasker decided to
simply plain ip3 retreating and
retreating the night taking control over
C 5 f6 and now this was a move to just
like destroyed convention chess
convention at the time
Alaska played the move f5 which looked
like just like the silliest move ever it
creates a backward pass pause
sr a backward pawn on e4 a weakness on
e5 it destroys the possibility of
breaking with E 5 myself and it just
doesn't seem like it's threatening
anything right like why why why a5
however last year had seen way way way
beyond that he saw that the stronghold
on e5 was not gonna be easily accessible
for for black further he saw that it
wasn't terribly important to dominate
this Bishop on c8
he wanted to make sure the bishop on c8
didn't have anything useful to do lastly
he wanted to eliminate the pair of
bishops so we're gonna see how all this
comes together
b6 was played Bishop f4 and fine and the
first serious mistake of the game back
up a block there should be seven I'm
gonna steal a little bit from Kasparov
but you know since the guys kind of get
now a serious mistake in general black
should be happy to under his seat bones
why not right there doubled but here the
pawn on d6 will become a permanent
weakness and you gotta understand this
is like 101 years ago we didn't really
have a full understanding of what
weaknesses are but nowadays we know that
weaknesses are only weak if they can be
attacked
therefore this double pawns we're not
really much of an issue I mean honestly
the pawns were quite a well placed they
defended each other and they kept the
Knights at bay so for example after the
continuation Bishop takes therefore
rotates at for c5 it's not entirely easy
to prove a white advantage I can play
Bishop d7 later I open up c6 for my
night
right so there's a lot of advantages to
it it's not so clear the black streak
that could I mean he's still 95 will be
an issue at some point so I would still
rather be white but definitely much
better than the game this should be
seven was played and then Bishop takes
takes at 94 already eyeing the square e
six rook ad a bad move kappa blanka
doesn't take White's plan seriously the
night only six will be a bone in his
throat Bishop c8 was mandatory and
meeting the mistake going back to ca to
defend the e6 square however we know as
chess players that one of the most
difficult things to do in chess is that
made a mistake going back is not easy
rook the eighth and ninety-six root D 7
root D 1 and we're just gonna see mr.
Lasker here play very very very
precisely before locking down the Queen
side and suddenly that Bishop on b7
you're looking very happy King F 783
simple domination he could at some point
sacrifice the exchange on e6 but it's
not very likely that it really works you
don't have enough for the compensation
for the exchange you don't have enough
compensation by a long shot
however it was probably the best way of
surviving couple blocker doesn't want to
give up material and he was known to be
a rather stubborn player and sometimes
it showed he played Bishop a8 and after
king of turu k 7 he tried to create
counter play by opening up the a file
something that's simply like boomerangs
back to him
g4 h6 rook t3 and now it's very natural
for white to start opening on the King
side black doesn't have a lot of pieces
there and we have this Maxim that when
you have more space it's useful to open
up different flanks because it's more
difficult for your opponent to bring
pieces into the flat into both flanks so
a 5h4 takes takes route g7 King f3
just improving the position no rush no
rush the Kings better placed on f4 than
it is on f2 so just get it there for
Jade care for g6 route g3 yeah
well he realized there was nothing to do
with the file there was just like
nothing to do he thought that he by
opening the file he might be able to
create some counterplay and it's
probably expecting him Alaska - sorry
couple Lanka was probably expecting
Lasker to go some kind of quick g5 but I
mean he didn't just improve the position
and ask the question like okay what are
you doing you're not doing anything down
the a file so g5 check was played can
you have 396 kind of desperation takes
takes and now control the file here on
h3 a very nice move much better than the
tempting rook takes t6 which would win a
pawn but after 94 route d1 rotate shade
maybe things are not so clear because
the rogue gets a nice position then I
could go to e5 unnecessary rook h3 and
rook d7 was played 94 is no longer a
good idea because after rook a1 the
combined invasion of both rooks than the
H and a file system possible to stop
rook d7 was played now king g3 is very
patient he didn't want to be checked on
e5 of the night ever landed on c4 just
very very patient
kingi aid from da chuan Bishop h7 and
the final touch of the game 'if I've a
move that looks quite dumb because after
all this part can be taken in two
different ways but the clearance gained
and the decisive effect of the night
coming into the game wraps up after pawn
takes e5 94 notice the useless Bishop on
C on b7 there's a threat on f6 almost
impossible to stop 95 96 to c5 throwing
the rook and the bishop rooks bishops e8
this is kind of the position that you
look at well might as well sacrifice to
exchange like 20 moves ago Bishop Knight
takes design by the way anything else
lost right if you play this they stakes
and check so
double attacker so you have to go
bishops you take stakes and now Luke age
seven and the rest is pretty much
history with the thread of 96 or ruk t7
check Andrew take CA checkmate
complete and absolute domination it was
a funny you know Safari game it really
had a lot of a big impression on Kappa
Blanc you know he was a relatively
emotional player sometimes for example
against Lasker in the world championship
match seven years later he never once
played a six in the real Lopes he never
allowed the exchange also he absolutely
crumbled in his next game last year was
actually not half a point behind he was
a point and a half behind but capablanca
was still ahead but he has still had to
play dr. Sigma Parrish on the next round
I kappa blanka collapsed he wasn't ready
to play after his defeat and tires took
full advantage of it it's not the most
exciting of games but a huge blunder
basically cost him the tournament in
this position after rook takes e5 cup of
Malacca thought of a kind of clever idea
and it ended up not and being not so
clever so he could take on he could just
play Bishop takes e5 and played this
kind of weird end game with two pieces
against the rook and upon probably
little better for black rook fd1 is
probably okay also and after Bishop g4
he really needs to play the following
rook takes d6 Bishop takes f3 Rick takes
f6 and if you count pieces at the end I
think white ends up like with a slightly
better position with an even amount of
material with correct continuation but
instead he thought he was going to be
tricky and played the move Queen g3
the point being that after take stakes
I'm attacking the Queen and the night
therefore if the Queen retreats I can
take take take and I end up an extra
pawn work up a block I forgot was that
after Queen d2
there's a little checkmate problem on
anyone and after the move of f3 and at
age 5 Queen f2 takes takes he's simply
down a piece and as much fluttering as
much cup of Blanca as he was a pieces of
piece and towers had absolutely no
problems converting come on Blanca went
on to win his final two rounds against
marshal and yo him I want to say why
whereas last year won off his remaining
games allowing Lasker to take the 1914
st. Petersburg chess tournament now
we're gonna take a couple a look at a
couple of other important games ok
capablanca looks like an idiot so we're
gonna make him look good he played one
of the most impressive games I think of
the era against nimzowitsch now aron
nimzowitsch he was he hadn't yet
published my system which is his legacy
right
when everybody thinks just good books
books you must read everybody thinks
nimzowitsch my system that's considered
to be one of the Holy Grails of chess
it's a little dated there's a lot of
things that don't apply it's not like
Carlsen you know make some movement
things with nimzowitsch approve of this
but at the same time you know his
influence in chess has been tremendous
he was he we have hyper modern chess
because of him we have a lot of ways of
thinking of chess that were based on him
and knezovich didn't actually he wasn't
at his peak right now if I had to say
when was nimzowitsch at his peak I would
say that the Carlsbad tournament of 1921
1929 was his crowning jewel and that was
when you know there was way big way
after that
so we're gonna take a look at the
remnants of it again supposed to rubble
kappa blanka we're gonna have a steinitz
type of defense in the spanish not
something that's considered to be
mainline anymore it's supposed to be a
little uncomfortable for a block you
know you have some problems in certain
variations it's kind of a little passive
and nobody likes to be passive so d4 is
considered to be the main idea it should
be seven takes takes Queen d3 by
exchanging his bishop on c6 White has
forced black to give up his outpost on
the center since there is no decent way
of defending the pawn on e5 if I play
Queen e7 then my bishops kind of just
blocked in right and I really want to
play that also there are problems after
for example pawn takes pawn takes Bishop
g5 of a follow up with 95 or even d5 as
uncomfortable as it is so Queen stammers
not something anybody wants to play it
takes takes and now one of the weirdest
things that happen in this tournament
this was new at the time and you gotta
understand and it's hard to sometimes
explain this game but this was 1914 and
the idea of the bank of gambit didn't
exist nobody thought the banker gambit
mainly because banker wasn't even born
yet
all right this is 1914 g6 this move
actually invites white to win a pawn
after knight c6 which was played b c6
queen a6
there is no good way of defending this
pawn if I play Queen d7 which was played
in the game because after for example c5
check is devastating
97 would be forced and what another
Bishop g5 you cannot take this Bishop
because of Queen a8 right you cannot
move
because 95 and everything is hanging in
97 this thing including eight is hanging
this Knight f6 check is hanging horrible
and if you play Bishop II salmon then
after takes you have to take with the
King again because of the rook on a aid
check and then take on c7 if you need to
so kappa blanka has to play Queen d7
but then after Queen b7 how do you
defend the work
yeah
you could play the Queen down right
queen c8 or queen da it works but then
who is defending the pony
check right very similar to the other
variation except you're down upon so
rook c8 was played and after Queen takes
Bishop g7 castles castles it looked like
White's up upon you got one two three
four five six seven one two three four
five six boys up upon its healthy
there's no weaknesses White has a little
bit of you know little lagging on
development but it's not a big deal I'll
catch up pretty quickly but somehow
capablanca you know back in 1914
understood that this open files that the
combination between the fianchettoed
Bishop there wasn't even a word for King
cared about them en Cairo Bishop with
the rooks and the idea that the pawn on
c5 could help the bishop on g7 it was so
foreign to everybody that it nobody
understood and it's impossible to blame
nimzowitsch for going into something
like this it looks like an extra pawn
nowadays we know that it's not so easy
there are some problems i kappa blanka
plays masterfully queen a 6-row Kaffee a
the queen retreats back to d3 in order
to defend the pawn queen e6 f3 and the
beautiful ideas it's like this guy
brings magic for every single piece 97
the knight reroutes in order to go to c4
trying to at some point provoke b3
Bishop d2 not a good move basically here
nimzowitsch didn't know what was going
on he thought he was chillin with an
extra pawn 95 Queen e2 Knight c4
problems already there are some problems
I cannot for example just kick out the
night because after Knight takes Queen
takes Knight Queen e5 I'm attacking this
Knight
and you cannot move it there's a rope
behind it for example 9 a 4x4 swap the
Queens and then the exchange at the end
right something similar would happen
against 92 I go check move the Queen out
of the way and then the rook on anyone
is still hanging
so after 94 in him so which defended his
pawn with rook b1 also moving the rook
out of the way
however here capablanca kept up the
pressure rook e8 threatening Bishop
takes c3 rook takes 8 - well kind of it
wants a pawn but I'm not really sure
kappa blanka would have done it given a
chance another idea here is for example
if white goes b3 then after takes takes
we know this concepts of blockades ruk 8
3 preventing the move a4 therefore after
I move my rook to a8 or I play Queen e5
I'm at some point going to regain my
pawn with a very obvious initiative at
some point it's just obvious that black
has a lot of play whereas White's pieces
you know they're not doing that much
a4 was played not the clever is the
Moose but after Bishop takes Bishop
takes rook takes b3 is not pleasant
since that Knight takes Queen takes and
now here black could we capture the porn
by taking taking and playing okay for
but unfortunately for him that the end
Queen c6 is still hanging right so this
is all no possible Queen c4 is a much
better move adding that pressure still
down upon but look at how this pressure
is mounting yeah
well I think that given the choice and
then I just made it rather than for what
takes takes and okay - I think given the
choice I don't think he would have
weakened his dark squares so much to the
bishop I think that he would have just
mounted the pressure you know clearly
for him the way that he was play he
wasn't in a rush to like regain the pawn
he was making his position better and
better and better it wasn't like a
phantom phantom threat it was just like
the rooks well placed there the Knight
has to defend a - if the person if the
possibility presents itself I'll take
the pawn but maybe I could do it in a
more in a better way like for example in
all the lines that we looked at where
the night takes well when I force b3 the
knight takes the queen takes and I can
force the knight out of the way for
example those variations are important
that the rooks on a8 because it's
attacking a - also for example the lines
that we looked at b3 Knight takes Queen
takes through k3 clamping down on the
Queen side right also an important
position for the rook so we're going to
add it's not like it's necessarily
threatening the pawn now but it's kind
of turning the phone yeah it's a
lingering threat right putting pressure
we call it putting pressure and now here
Queen c4 more pressure you pressure c3
you pressure 84 rook FD 1 was played and
now this is what I'm talking about here
Capablanca can actually play Bishop c3
and after Queen c3 pawn c3 pawn rook
takes rook d7 it looks like a pretty
draw a Shen game White has kind of real
problems with C 3 and C 2 where even
material right now that kappa blanka
regained his pawn but there's also some
problems with c7 phone and you know
what's pretty active you know I'm gonna
have to have this rook be passive in
order to defend this pawn
I don't know doesn't feel right and
Kappa black it just wasn't interested
you just didn't want the pawn rookie b8
bring in the bringing in the cavalry
there's an immediate threat rook takes
b2 would be a threat if for example h3
takes takes bishop c3 clean c1 takes
takes rook takes or queen takes or
whatever and I'm up upon right so it's
not like I just regained my material I
won material it's different queen III
which was a mistake and bam
rook be for threats everywhere
Bishop D Forsyth Retta the point is that
the rook is reinforcing the square right
queen g5 check King h1 rook be a still
down upon still not taking his free
material just putting in more pressure
but man now it looks like White's
position is collapsing the threat is
Bishop c3 and there is no one to defend
the rook on b1 also b2 is hanging and if
you play b3 the Knights hanging so here
White's stuck he can't defend he can't
move there's a serious threat the knight
doesn't even have a good square right
the knight doesn't have it strapped on
c3 rook takes d4 was played and after
Queen takes t4 as Kasparov pointed out
rook was the right price for this
powerful Bishop a bishop that did so
much hiding on g7 that the seumas had
saw the light a rook had to go in and
trade itself for it so Queen takes d4
route d1 Quincy 4 and now this is just
easy for kappa blanka up an exchange
still with the continuing pressure on
the King side h4 rook takes P to Queen
d2 Queen c5
Ruki one queen h5 bouquet one no plan at
all just making moves waiting for death
if queen f2 then the correct route take
c2 would have finished if Queen takes
check your check
therefore R okay one Queen h4 checking
g1 and will an extra piece sorry an
extra an exchange and upon pretty easy
for kebab Lanka some passed pawn that
was extra at some point only March
restores its death and now the phone is
captured ePHI for some desperation I
guess I'll lift up let the pawn live a
little longer danger in that Chuck and
d5 just a little more exact than rook a7
and 94 with some threats of Knight f6
and something something this actually
doesn't work but whatever there's no
need for to go like that you can just
play d5 okay ch4 takes 91 might be 4
kappa blanka could play his move our
names re-signed down exchange in three
pawns i'm pretty sure that i kappa
blanka could have easily won this and
the tobacco filled room of the st.
petersburg chess Society back in 1914
Capablanca was already a very dominant
player for his time and it's a little
surprising that he didn't win the event
but it was also a way for Lasker who had
already been world champion for 20 years
to prove that he was still top of his
game
Lasker was the world champion that had
held his title the longest at 27 years
it was kappa blanka that took it 7 years
later so you know Oscar had been brought
champion for quite a while so kappa
blanka vs. you'll see bird stein one of
the top players in the world remember
this are the top players in the world
right there there was nothing better
than this if they weren't there it's
because of political tension or because
they were too old
and this kappa blanka playing against
burst and he makes him look ridiculous
d4 d5 Knight f3 Knight of 6 c4 e6 and we
have a position that's not considered to
be very good for black nowadays but
again theory in the that decade was not
exactly up to date you 45 takes 94 I'm
just gonna skip ahead to like the meat
of the game and it was kind of like this
position where it's it seems kind of
complicated White's got obviously really
good development but there are some
issues for example once white black
castles there's a lot of pressure on f2
you know the Knights on g4 the bishops
already on c5 it just seems like if
black is able to finish his development
without a hiccup he might be in a good
position but a cup of black I was not in
the mood for anybody to finish any
developing v4 well first see the
sacrifice Bishop takes is kind of weak
to 95 and then Queen d6 takes takes 95
at the very least regain some material
so ok we're gonna focus on Bishop a7 and
then Bishop takes b5 sacrificing a
bishop pawn takes Knight takes d5 now
this knight cannot be taken because of
the rook paint on C's on the C file it's
a queen da de then check and kappa
blanka was never known as a romantic
player he wasn't known for his
aggressive attacks and stuff like that
but it's not like the guy couldn't do it
he could as we will see King f8 rook c6
Knight b6 Bishop h4 and now a nice
little idea after Queen d7 kappa blanka
took on c8 if you trade off pieces then
at the end rocket Raiders lethal since
the rook
so I wrote the eight chukkers lethal
since the rook on h8
has no defender the same would happen
against 98 first simply ripped check so
you cannot trade queens sorry you cannot
trade queens as well this night would be
immune but this night is threatening
night takes b6 and I'm still threatening
rogue d8 you cannot take immediately
because Queen takes T 790 67 leaves this
rook undefended rooks eh I can block
would have to resign so instead bursting
took the rook and now we went for a
little walk
check king of sub green e8
Chuck kept seven Chuck King g6 now no
good is to take on eh because after rook
takes d8 Bishop takes da roof takes eh I
am down a piece I still have three pawns
which is sufficient compensation but not
more than that instead the King hunt
continues check King aged five and now
after Knight takes eh the differences
that I have to wrote the eight I have
Chuck on g7 community six check King H 5
H 3 simply threatening the night but if
the knight retreats in this position
well where would it go
if Knight h6 which is the only possible
position where it's not lost then g7
Chuck made first and give up the night
but after Chuck takes Bishop takes rook
takes kappa blanka sup a solid three
pawns with the win of the night and well
couple Blanc in an endgame with an extra
pawn is pretty dangerous with three
that's not fun
after some moves where he managed to
untangle eventually kappa blanka won
without too many problems obviously this
is already reasonable
I remember what that move was about
America and black resigns there's just
too much material a deficit so that was
kind of like the nicest combination
probably of the tournament I kappa
blanka won the special price for
brilliancy thanks to this game and we're
bursting back when brilliancy prices for
I think nowadays we have like best game
price but I think brilliance here in
itself is not not exactly correct but
still it was a really nice game from
capablanca you know he wasn't known as
the sharpest of players in that scenario
when you think who would win a
brilliancy price in the day I turned him
that had Marshall and Lasker and
Alyokhina you know you would always say
like well probably Alec kind you know
like that guy guy wins all the
brilliancy prices but no I was kappa
blanka that showed that he could
sacrifice a piece of two and then make
his king opponent's king walk all the
way to h5 it was pretty cool so since we
have we're short running short on time
we're just going to see how last care
finished off the tournament he had to
win this game to guarantee himself first
place but he was playing Frank James
Marshall definitely not an easy opponent
sorry we had a Petrov yes I know this is
not the most exciting but this is 1914
and somehow they always make it exciting
and just to repeat what Kasparov said
about the position black is just one
move away from happiness after castling
on the Queen side his two bishops
against the dubious knight on h4 would
cause white considerable trouble but but
last carry it's too good for that
Queen b5 predicting that black had to
castle long so long castles because
there was nothing else to defend on b7
and now Lasker doesn't fall for the
following if Knight d5 and then after
takes takes Chuck attacking the Queen
and the king forcing the trade the
nice little pin there right so therefore
this is not possible but that's not how
he wanted to do he wanted to go for the
throat not possible to play King v8
because after 95 you cannot defend both
a7 and c7 so he played a6 and last care
also he wanted his brilliancy price
takes takes King BA but okay
there's nothing immediate night b5
threatens check and checkmate or Chuck
made on a on a it somehow so Knight b6
defends the pawn on c7 and defense Hey
right rook t3 bringing in the pieces
green g5 Chuck King here Bishop d6
Marshall also try to bring in his pieces
rogue b3 just bringing more stuff into
the into the fire for a Keiichi 8a for
slow but powerful Bishop f5 clot trying
for some kind of fluttering
counter-attack with like I don't know
rocky to maybe sacrificing only c2 and
rookie to or something whatever Knight a
7 it's running a checkmate in one right
there should be seven a five Queen d2
takes check King a to see six now
Marshall is obviously not having the
game of his life but it looks like for
now he's holding on maybe the Knights
still not part of the plate in the game
the night looks stuck here right
but Lasker came up with a really nice
final combination to win the game ninth
b5 threatening well Jack and Chuck made
with the pawn right pawn takes looks
forced and then Chuck I'm black resigned
because after Chuck can c8 check this
should be eight it doesn't look like I
have much but I have Queen a6 it's not
the most usual checkmate pattern but
after Queen a7 this is all forest here
Chuck here checkmate
and that was how Lasker ended up
victorious yeah yeah the problem with
bringing this rook is that he can still
take right and then you always want to
Blake checkmate if it's checkmate
because it finishes the game immediately
and this is not so clear actually well
you could play quenice ex-mate I guess
but uh yeah the idea is that you play
Queen a6 so you know Lasker still had it
you still had proved that he was one of
the best players in the world and he
warn't one of what was you know one of
the historically most important
tournaments and as I was saying also
because of the political tensions that
were surrounding the tournament at the
time you know the it was an ambivalence
between all the the war and or there was
about to sprout and this tournament in
the Russian newspapers those were the
two main stories you know and it was
just a treat for everybody for one whole
month st. Petersburg was focused on its
chest